This is 99% Invisible. I'm Chris Birube, sitting in this week for Roman Mars. In Woonsocket, Rhode Island, there's one surefire way to get yourself clocked as an out-of-towner. Is it Woonsocket? Woon. Woonsocket. Woonsocket. Yep. No double O. No woo. No woo.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是克里斯·比鲁贝，本周代班罗曼·马尔斯。在罗德岛州的文索基特，有一个万无一失的方法能让你被一眼认出是外地人。是文索基特（Woonsocket）吗？Woon。Woonsocket。Woonsocket。没错。没有双O。没有woo。没有woo。
No woo. No woo! No woo! This past spring, producer Jason DeLeon drove to, uh, One Socket, which is just a few miles up the road from where he lives. And in One Socket, I met up with Jean Michonne. Jean is Native American and French-Canadian. So technically, her name is... Jean. God's gift to man. That's what it means. Really? Yeah, my mother had a sense of humor. Pronunciation aside, everyone calls her Jean.
没有woo。没有woo！没有woo！今年春天，制片人杰森·德莱昂开车去了，呃，One Socket，离他住的地方只有几英里远。在One Socket，我见到了让·米雄。让是美洲原住民和法裔加拿大人。所以严格来说，她的名字是……让（Jean）。上帝赐予人类的礼物。这就是它的意思。真的吗？是的，我母亲很有幽默感。发音先不谈，大家都叫她让。
And Jean is third generation one socket. She grew up there in the 1970s. And back then, she said, the city had some stuff going for it. There were places to hang out, like the local movie theater, or the skating rink or the arcade. And because she loved to cook, Jean remembers always jumping at the chance to go with her mom to the grocery store. And that was the biggest thing ever. Woo, let's go. We're going shopping with mom.
让是第三代One Socket人。她在20世纪70年代在那里长大。她说，那时候，这座城市还是有些可取之处的。有很多消遣的地方，比如当地的电影院、溜冰场或游戏厅。因为她喜欢做饭，让记得总是抢着跟妈妈去杂货店。那可是天大的事。喔，走吧。我们要跟妈妈去购物了。
Woohoo. No, you're not getting nothing. At the time, Jean's family had a lot of options for grocers. There were small, locally owned stores like Fernandez Produce and Big D's. The city also had supermarkets, from regional chains like Star Market and Almax. The way some of these local shops bag groceries always mesmerized young Jean. After ringing them up, a cashier would place the groceries in a box on a giant conveyor belt which would crank out the side of the building. And everybody knew that you park there and then it'll come out to you.
喔呼。不，你什么也得不到。当时，让的家人有很多杂货店可选。有像Fernandez Produce和Big D's这样的小型本地商店。城市里也有超市，来自像Star Market和Almax这样的区域连锁店。这些本地商店装杂货的方式总是让年幼的让着迷。结账后，收银员会把杂货放进一个巨大的传送带上的盒子里，传送带会伸出建筑外。大家都知道，你把车停在那儿，东西就会送到你车边。
You know, dad would wait in the car while my kids were shopping, throwing whatever in the boxes. As the years went on, Wendsocket's economy took a turn for the worse. For decades, factory jobs had employed a lot of the city. But those jobs left, and pretty soon, the local movie theater closed. So did the skating rink and the arcade. Then the grocery stores started disappearing. We used to have Star Market, which was always packed on Diamond Hill, and then that one left. One by one, local grocers shut their doors
你知道，爸爸会在车里等，而我们孩子在购物，把东西随便往盒子里扔。随着岁月流逝，文索基特的经济每况愈下。几十年来，工厂工作养活了这座城市的大部分人。但这些工作岗位流失了，很快，当地的电影院关门了。溜冰场和游戏厅也关了。接着，杂货店开始消失。我们以前有Star Market，在Diamond Hill那家总是挤满了人，后来那家也关了。当地的杂货店一家接一家地关门，
and never reopened. The decline was so dramatic that today in Woonsocket, a city of 45,000, there's only one grocery store, a Price Right out on the edge of town. It's sad that people don't have other choices to make. And I'm not knocking Price Right, but when you have no choice, but to go to one place, it's like that's the oasis in the desert.
再也没有重开。衰落是如此剧烈，以至于今天在拥有4.5万人口的文索基特，只剩下一家杂货店，位于城郊的Price Right。人们没有其他选择，这很可悲。我并不是在贬低Price Right，但当你别无选择，只能去一个地方时，它就像沙漠中的绿洲。
This is the only spot that they can go to get refreshed is at this price right. Woonsocket is what's known as a food desert. These are low-income communities where it's hard to find groceries. According to the USDA, in a city like Woonsocket, that means lots of residents live more than a mile from the nearest grocery store. And while a mile in a city may not sound like much, according to the latest census information, nearly 20% of Woonsocket's residents don't have access to a vehicle. Pair that with unreliable public transportation, and suddenly a simple task like grabbing groceries can become a real struggle. On its face, the story of how Woonsocket turned into a food desert seems pretty straightforward.
这是他们唯一能去补充物资的地方，就是这家Price Right。文索基特被称为“食物沙漠”。这些是低收入社区，很难买到杂货。根据美国农业部的数据，在像文索基特这样的城市，这意味着许多居民距离最近的杂货店超过一英里。虽然在城市里一英里听起来不算什么，但根据最新的人口普查信息，近20%的文索基特居民没有私家车。再加上不可靠的公共交通，突然间，买杂货这样一件简单的事情就可能变成真正的挣扎。表面上看，文索基特变成食物沙漠的故事似乎很简单。
The city fell on hard times, then businesses abandoned ship, and now it's harder to get basic things like groceries. But the actual story of how when socket and places like it became food deserts is more complicated than that. The common assumption about why food deserts exist, both in the academic literature and among policymakers, is that these are communities that can't support a supermarket. You know, they're either too poor or too small to generate enough spending on groceries and therefore can't support a supermarket.
城市陷入困境，企业弃船而去，现在获取杂货等基本物资变得更难了。但关于文索基特和类似地方如何变成食物沙漠的真实故事要复杂得多。学术文献和政策制定者对食物沙漠存在的原因有一个普遍假设，即这些社区无法支撑一家超市。你知道，它们要么太穷，要么太小，无法产生足够的杂货消费，因此无法支撑一家超市。
Stacy Mitchell is a food researcher and co-executive director at the Institute for Local Self-Reliance. And she thinks this general understanding of food deserts misses the bigger picture. Food deserts didn't used to exist. You know, poverty has been with us forever. But food deserts only arose in the late 1980s. And so this explanation that we have that food deserts are really kind of like there's something wrong with the community, like the community itself is deficient in some way and therefore can't support a supermarket.
斯泰西·米切尔是一位食品研究员，也是地方自力更生研究所的联合执行主任。她认为这种对食物沙漠的普遍理解忽略了更大的图景。食物沙漠过去并不存在。你知道，贫困一直伴随着我们。但食物沙漠直到20世纪80年代末才出现。所以我们这种解释，即食物沙漠是因为社区本身出了问题，比如社区本身在某种程度上存在缺陷，因此无法支撑一家超市，
That's not actually why we have food deserts. Everybody eats, you know, poor neighborhoods spend a lot of money on grocery stores. It's not that there's not enough spending in these neighborhoods. Like something else happened. It's easy to think of food deserts as a natural consequence of poverty. But in communities like Woonsocket, grocery stores stuck around well into the 1990s, long after the factories closed and the city's fortunes faded. Stacey Mitchell says the real reason these food deserts emerged all across the country
这其实并不是我们有食物沙漠的原因。每个人都要吃饭，你知道，贫困社区在杂货店上花了很多钱。并不是这些社区的消费不足。而是发生了别的事情。人们很容易把食物沙漠看作贫困的自然结果。但在像文索基特这样的社区，杂货店一直开到了20世纪90年代，远在工厂倒闭和城市财富消退之后。斯泰西·米切尔说，这些食物沙漠在全国各地出现的真正原因，
is because of a decades-long battle over one policy. The story of this policy fight starts with the rise of one of America's first national grocery chains, the Great Atlantic and Pacific Tea Company, better known as AMP. We watch our P's and Q's and A&P. We know you'll be back. For these little green guys. They're our specials of the week. A&P started as a tea company in lower Manhattan,
是因为一场围绕一项政策持续了几十年的斗争。这场政策斗争的故事始于美国第一批全国性连锁杂货店之一——大西洋和太平洋茶叶公司（Great Atlantic and Pacific Tea Company），即众所周知的A&P的崛起。我们注意我们的P和Q，还有A&P。我们知道你会回来的。为了这些绿色小家伙。它们是我们本周的特价商品。A&P最初是曼哈顿下城的一家茶叶公司，
but at the turn of the 20th century, the retailer expanded into the grocery business. At the time, the industry was mostly composed of small independent neighborhood grocers. These mom-and-pop shops would often take orders by phone and then deliver them to your house. They also operated on a credit system, so instead of settling the bill with every purchase, customers would just pay a tab at the end of the month. However, deliveries can get expensive, and operating on a credit system exposed these
但在20世纪之交，这家零售商扩展到了杂货业务。当时，该行业主要由小型独立社区杂货商组成。这些夫妻店通常通过电话接单，然后送到你家。他们还实行信用制度，所以顾客不用每次购买都结账，而是在月底支付账单。然而，送货成本很高，而且实行信用制度使这些
grocers to big losses. Sometimes people just didn't pay up. So to cover shortfalls, they'd often mark up their prices. But with the arrival of AMP came a new business model. AMP did away with deliveries and purchases on credit. Instead, at your local A&P, customers would approach the counter and pay on the spot with cash. They also cut costs by vertically integrating their business.
杂货商面临巨大损失。有时人们就是不付钱。为了弥补亏空，他们通常会提高价格。但随着A&P的到来，出现了一种新的商业模式。A&P取消了送货和赊账购买。相反，在当地的A&P，顾客走到柜台前，用现金当场支付。他们还通过垂直整合业务来削减成本。
The company owned manufacturing facilities, which produced A&P branded products, which they sold in A&P stores, all of which helped them offer the lowest prices in town. Prioritizing low prices is a pretty simple change, but it was existential for all of those mom and pop shops. There's a lot of alarm across the country about AMP. You know, they're opening all of these stores, they're putting lots of local grocers out of business and really just taking over the market very rapidly. By the early 1930s, AMP had expanded from grocery stores in the New York metro area
该公司拥有生产设施，生产A&P品牌的商品，并在A&P商店销售，所有这些都帮助他们提供了城里最低的价格。优先考虑低价是一个非常简单的改变，但对所有那些夫妻店来说却是生死攸关的。全国各地对A&P都有很多恐慌。你知道，他们开了这么多店，让很多当地杂货商倒闭，而且确实在非常迅速地接管市场。到20世纪30年代初，A&P已从纽约大都会区的杂货店扩展到
to more than 15,000 stores nationwide. While other chain stores existed, A&P perfected the model. Even in places like Winsocket, A&P had multiple stores throughout the city. And with all that growth, A&P achieved something no retailer in America had ever done before. It produced more than a billion dollars in sales. And the company used all this money and power as a weapon. In negotiations with suppliers, A&P knew that it had the upper hand. And so the company leveraged its size not only to get the very best deals, but to make life harder on their competition.
全国超过1.5万家门店。虽然其他连锁店也存在，但A&P完善了这个模式。即使在像文索基特这样的地方，A&P在全城也有多家门店。随着所有这些增长，A&P实现了美国零售商从未做到的事情。它的销售额超过了10亿美元。该公司利用所有的金钱和权力作为武器。在与供应商的谈判中，A&P知道自己占据上风。因此，该公司利用其规模不仅获得了最好的交易，还让竞争对手的日子更难过。
The reason that A&P is growing so rapidly is that it's squeezing suppliers. It's going to suppliers and saying, we're your biggest customer and we want you to give us big discounts and other favors while raising the prices that you're charging our competitor down the street. This is what's known as the waterbed effect. When suppliers charged AMP less for its products, they made up for it by charging more to the small neighborhood grocers. So like a waterbed, if you sit on one side, the other side goes up. So in effect, what drives AMP's growth is that it has this kind of leverage that comes purely from its size.
A&P之所以增长如此迅速，是因为它在挤压供应商。它去找供应商说，我们是你最大的客户，我们希望你给我们大折扣和其他优惠，同时提高你向街对面竞争对手收取的价格。这就是所谓的“水床效应”。当供应商向A&P收取的费用减少时，他们通过向小型社区杂货商收取更多费用来弥补。就像水床一样，如果你坐在这一边，另一边就会鼓起来。所以实际上，推动A&P增长的是它纯粹因规模而产生的这种杠杆作用。
In the 1930s, AMP was viewed by many as a monopoly, and its size was a huge issue in the country. The company was known to blacklist suppliers who didn't bend to their will. It also extracted big fees from farmers and manufacturers to carry their products. From the federal government all the way down to high school debate classes, people argued about AMP and how big is too big. AMP is like changing the fabric of neighborhoods and of towns. It's coming in and running out of business, a lot of local businesses. So there's this big backlash all across the country.
在20世纪30年代，A&P被许多人视为垄断企业，其规模是国内的一个巨大问题。众所周知，该公司会将不屈服于其意志的供应商列入黑名单。它还向农民和制造商收取高额费用以销售他们的产品。从联邦政府一直到高中辩论课，人们都在争论A&P以及多大才算太大。A&P正在改变社区和城镇的结构。它进来并让许多当地企业倒闭。所以全国各地都有这种巨大的反弹。
This pushback against AMP was part of a wider movement against chain stores in general. In small towns throughout the Midwest and the South, big chains threatened local businesses. And because AMP was the biggest chain store, it became the target of communities nationwide. Municipal governments tried to help small local grocers by taxing AMP. Some even passed laws to limit the number of stores it could open in a county. In Shreveport, Louisiana, a local radio station ran a whole program focused on fighting chain stores. A musician named Andrew Jenkins had a message for communities facing a takeover by the likes of AMP. when the hometown merges before it is too late.
这种对A&P的抵制是针对连锁店的更广泛运动的一部分。在中西部和南部的城镇里，大型连锁店威胁到了当地企业。由于A&P是最大的连锁店，它成为了全国社区的目标。市政当局试图通过对A&P征税来帮助小型本地杂货商。有些人甚至通过法律限制它在一个县内可以开设的门店数量。在路易斯安那州的什里夫波特，当地一家广播电台制作了一个专门针对打击连锁店的节目。一位名叫安德鲁·詹金斯的音乐家向面临A&P式接管的社区传达了一个信息：在家乡合并之前，为时未晚。
In the 1930s, the anger with chain stores was also part of a broader frustration with the economy. Many people felt the system just wasn't serving the working class. After all, A&P crossed a billion dollars in sales during the Great Depression. While the low prices helped cash-strapped Americans, it was notable that A&P's rise coincided with the lowest point in many people's lives.
在20世纪30年代，对连锁店的愤怒也是对经济更广泛挫败感的一部分。许多人觉得这个系统根本没有服务于工人阶级。毕竟，A&P在大萧条期间销售额突破了10亿美元。虽然低价帮助了手头拮据的美国人，但值得注意的是，A&P的崛起恰逢许多人生活的最底层。
Soon, Congress picked up on all this outrage. A&P built up its power during an era of relatively lax antitrust enforcement. But as part of FDR's New Deal, corporate power was under intense scrutiny. And with one new piece of legislation, two lawmakers set their sights on breaking up the power of AMP. So in 1936, they passed a law called the Robinson-Patman Act.
很快，国会注意到了所有这些愤怒。A&P在反垄断执法相对宽松的时代建立了权力。但作为罗斯福“新政”的一部分，企业权力受到了严格审查。通过一项新的立法，两名议员将目光投向了打破A&P的权力。于是，在1936年，他们通过了一项名为《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》（Robinson-Patman Act）的法律。
And it's an antitrust law, and it outlaws what is known as price discrimination. The Robinson-Patman Act was the brainchild of Senator Joseph Robinson from Arkansas and Congressman Wright Patman from Texas. And it gave the federal government a new tool to rein in monopolistic power. The law was even nicknamed the Anti-ANP Act. For years, AMP pressured suppliers into giving them the best deals. But the Robinson-Patman Act changed that dynamic. It outlawed price discrimination, which means that whatever sweet deal AMP received from a supplier
这是一项反垄断法，它取缔了所谓的“价格歧视”。《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》是阿肯色州参议员约瑟夫·罗宾逊和德克萨斯州众议员赖特·帕特曼的结晶。它为联邦政府提供了一个遏制垄断权力的新工具。该法案甚至被称为“反A&P法案”。多年来，A&P向供应商施压，要求获得最好的交易。但《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》改变了这种动态。它取缔了价格歧视，这意味着A&P从供应商那里获得的任何优惠交易，
had to be the same sweet deal offered to other retailers, including small independent grocers. The law makes it illegal for suppliers to provide different prices to different buyers. It also makes it illegal for retailers that have market power to demand special deals, discounts, other kinds of favorable treatment. One big hang up that people had with the Robinson-Patman Act is this idea that it banned bulk discounts. But that's not exactly true. Big chains could still get a lower price for buying in bulk. Other retailers just needed access to the same terms.
都必须同样提供给其他零售商，包括小型独立杂货商。该法律规定供应商向不同买家提供不同价格是非法的。它还规定拥有市场权力的零售商要求特殊交易、折扣或其他形式的优惠待遇是非法的。人们对《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》的一个大顾虑是它禁止批量折扣。但这并不完全正确。大型连锁店仍然可以因批量购买而获得更低的价格。其他零售商只需要获得相同的条款即可。
The goal was to make retailers compete over things like innovation, product selection, and customer service, rather than using purely market power to shove competition out. A&P tried to persuade the public that its size wasn't a problem. In a magazine profile, the president of the company warned that breaking up their power would actually raise grocery prices. And in one newspaper ad, ANP thumbed its nose at antitrust enforcers by showing a picture of the Empire State Building with a caption that read, It's far too big. It ought to be seven buildings. Still, the Federal Trade Commission and the Department of Justice kept pressuring the company. And after Robinson-Patman went into effect, the changes
目标是让零售商在创新、产品选择和客户服务等方面竞争，而不是纯粹利用市场权力将竞争对手挤出市场。A&P试图说服公众，其规模不是问题。在一份杂志简介中，该公司总裁警告说，打破他们的权力实际上会提高杂货价格。在一则报纸广告中，A&P展示了一张帝国大厦的照片，配文写道：“它太大了。它应该是七座建筑。”以此嘲弄反垄断执法者。尽管如此，联邦贸易委员会和司法部仍不断向该公司施压。在《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》生效后，
to the grocery business were almost immediate. The law ate into AMP's profits. And within a few years, the company's exponential growth looked a lot more like normal growth. The steep decline of the small neighborhood grocer was headed off. AMP is no longer, you know, sort of aggressively like gobbling up the entire market. They're stopped from doing that, but they're still, you know, a force. The Robinson-Patman Act didn't destroy AMP. It just stopped the company from abusing its
杂货业的变化几乎是立竿见影的。该法律削减了A&P的利润。几年之内，该公司的指数级增长看起来更像是正常增长。小型社区杂货商的急剧衰落得到了遏制。A&P不再像以前那样咄咄逼人地吞噬整个市场。他们被阻止这样做，但他们仍然是一股力量。《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》并没有摧毁A&P。它只是阻止了该公司滥用其
power. Big chain grocers continued to thrive and operate nationwide. And small grocers could still serve their communities. There was a semblance of balance in the grocery business. Independent grocers, you know, including, you know, sort of single location grocery stores and very small, like family owned chains that had a handful of stores. Those retailers maintain more than half of all grocery sales from the 1940s all the way through the early 1980s. So from a consumer's perspective, it's like the best of both worlds because almost every
权力。大型连锁杂货店继续在全国范围内蓬勃发展和运营。小型杂货商仍然可以服务于他们的社区。杂货业出现了一种平衡的表象。独立杂货商，包括单店杂货店和拥有少量门店的非常小的家族连锁店，从20世纪40年代一直到80年代初，占据了所有杂货销售额的一半以上。所以从消费者的角度来看，这就像是两全其美，因为几乎每个
neighborhood has this choice. If you want to shop at an independent grocery store, you have that option. But if you prefer to shop at, say, Kroger or Safeway, you also have that option. There's this incredible diversity and variety and competition, and it's all really resting on the fact that we had the Robinson-Patman Act and enforced it. For decades, the Robinson-Patman Act helped create a more level playing field in the grocery business. But it would soon get swept up in a huge campaign to rewrite the rules of American antitrust. After the break, one man's quest to break the Robinson-Patman Act
社区都有这种选择。如果你想在独立杂货店购物，你有这个选择。但如果你更喜欢在克罗格（Kroger）或西夫韦（Safeway）购物，你也有这个选择。这种令人难以置信的多样性、品种和竞争，实际上都建立在我们拥有并执行了《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》的事实之上。几十年来，《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》帮助在杂货业创造了一个更公平的竞争环境。但它很快就会被一场重写美国反垄断规则的巨大运动所席卷。休息之后，一个人打破《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》的追求，
and the rise of food deserts. From the 1930s into the 1970s, the Federal Trade Commission aggressively enforced the Robinson-Pabin Act. It issued citations and cease and desist orders to companies who violated the law. This had the effect of reining in powerful chains like AMP. It also acted as a deterrent to other businesses who might be on the verge of their very own monopolistic power trip. But the backlash from big business was always coming. Since the New Deal, antitrust laws like Robinson-Patman acted as a check on corporate power. But in the 1970s, a new school of economic thought took hold.
以及食物沙漠的兴起。从20世纪30年代到70年代，联邦贸易委员会积极执行《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》。它向违反法律的公司发出传票和停止令。这起到了遏制像A&P这样强大的连锁店的作用。它也对其他可能处于垄断权力边缘的企业起到了威慑作用。但来自大企业的反弹总是会来的。自“新政”以来，像《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》这样的反垄断法一直是制约企业权力的手段。但在20世纪70年代，一种新的经济思想流派占据了上风。
It argued that traditional FDR-era antitrust enforcement was actually holding the American economy back. And to unlock America's full economic potential, we needed to completely rethink antitrust. A key figure in the dismantling of our antitrust laws is Robert Bork. Robert Bork was a professor of antitrust law at Yale, but he's probably best known for his political career. He was the one who carried out Nixon's order to fire the special prosecutor investigating Watergate. The Saturday Night Massacre? That's Robert Bork.
它认为传统的罗斯福时代反垄断执法实际上阻碍了美国经济的发展。为了释放美国的全部经济潜力，我们需要彻底重新思考反垄断。拆除我们反垄断法的关键人物是罗伯特·博克（Robert Bork）。罗伯特·博克是耶鲁大学的反垄断法教授，但他最出名的可能是他的政治生涯。正是他执行了尼克松解雇调查水门事件的特别检察官的命令。“星期六之夜大屠杀”？那就是罗伯特·博克。
Bork's name was also famously turned into a verb after his failed confirmation to the Supreme Court. He got Borked. As an academic, Bork was part of this rising tide of scholars trying to reshape antitrust in a more free market direction. And to help do that, he published a book in 1978 that became a manifesto for the movement. He writes this book called The Antitrust Paradox. And you know, it is a kind of bestseller, if you will, for a policy book. And it has this incredible influence across the right and even to some degree among Democrats.
博克的名字在最高法院提名失败后也著名地变成了一个动词。他被“博克了”（Borked）。作为一名学者，博克是试图以更自由市场的方向重塑反垄断的学者浪潮的一部分。为了帮助实现这一目标，他在1978年出版了一本书，成为了该运动的宣言。他写了这本书，叫《反垄断悖论》（The Antitrust Paradox）。你知道，对于一本政策书籍来说，它算是一种畅销书。它在右翼甚至在某种程度上在民主党人中产生了令人难以置信的影响。
In the antitrust paradox, Bork argues that for decades American antitrust claimed to be about protecting competition and consumers. But in reality, antitrust only protected inefficient companies and punished the successful ones. And this paradox, he said, actually harmed consumers because it led to higher prices. At the time, Bork's argument had a receptive audience. The American economy struggled during the 70s with high inflation and low growth. Grocery prices were skyrocketing, and Bork insisted traditional antitrust enforcement was making
在《反垄断悖论》中，博克认为几十年来美国反垄断声称是为了保护竞争和消费者。但实际上，反垄断只保护了低效的公司，惩罚了成功的公司。他说，这种悖论实际上伤害了消费者，因为它导致了更高的价格。当时，博克的论点有接受它的受众。美国经济在70年代经历了高通胀和低增长的挣扎。杂货价格飞涨，博克坚持认为传统的反垄断执法正在使
things worse. And he didn't just throw tomatoes from the sidelines. In his book, Robert Bork laid out a new vision for antitrust. One that he claimed was based on a close, accurate reading of the nation's first antitrust laws. You know, Bork very much believed that corporations should be free to wield their power and do what they want and that the laws that we'd always understood to mean that we should disperse power, that we should prevent too much consolidation, that's not really what those laws were about. He thought that antitrust was all about efficiency, and big corporations tend to be more efficient. So you know what?
情况变得更糟。他不仅仅是在场边扔番茄。在他的书中，罗伯特·博克为反垄断提出了一个新的愿景。他声称这是基于对国家第一批反垄断法的仔细、准确的解读。你知道，博克非常相信公司应该自由地行使权力，做他们想做的事，而我们一直理解为应该分散权力、应该防止过度整合的法律，并不是这些法律的真正含义。他认为反垄断完全是为了效率，而大公司往往更有效率。所以你知道吗？
We should actually use antitrust to encourage corporate consolidation. So he like turned antitrust on its head? In Robert Bork's view, antitrust enforcement had been overly concerned with fairness. After all, fairness was subjective. A truly objective policy would use what he called the consumer welfare standard. And this new standard he came up with focused on prices over basically everything else.
我们实际上应该利用反垄断来鼓励企业整合。所以他把反垄断颠倒过来了？在罗伯特·博克的观点中，反垄断执法过于关注公平。毕竟，公平是主观的。一个真正客观的政策应该使用他所谓的“消费者福利标准”。他提出的这个新标准将价格置于几乎所有其他因素之上。
Part of how Bork and his cohort sell this idea is by saying that prices are measurable, efficiency is measurable. Like it's like one North Star. We can point antitrust to this. Like there's an answer to the problem or any question that's asked. We can find an answer. Like is this merger good or bad? Well, will it lead to lower prices?
博克和他的同僚推销这个想法的部分方式是说价格是可衡量的，效率是可衡量的。就像一颗北极星。我们可以把反垄断指向这个。就像问题或提出的任何问题都有答案一样。我们可以找到答案。比如这次合并是好是坏？嗯，它会导致价格降低吗？
That's one question, one answer that then guides policy. That's the thinking behind it. And to really help drive home his case for the consumer welfare standard, Robert Bork turned the Robinson-Patman Act into his punching bag. It should be said that almost the scholarly opinion on all sides of the antitrust issue is that the Robinson-Patman Act is a peculiarly pernicious statute. In his book, Bork calls the law, quote, anti-trust's least glorious hour.
这是一个问题，一个指导政策的答案。这就是背后的逻辑。为了真正推动他关于消费者福利标准的案例，罗伯特·博克把《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》变成了他的出气筒。应该说，反垄断问题各方的学术观点几乎都认为《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》是一部特别有害的法规。在他的书中，博克称该法为“反垄断最不光彩的时刻”。
Elsewhere, he called it the typhoid Mary of anti-trust. Robert Bork didn't just dislike the Robinson-Patman Act, he loathed it. So in his writing, he characterized it as this crazy, stupid law. And he creates this environment where for decades, any economist worth their salt, any legal scholar worth their salt, would never say that the Robinson-Patman Act was a good thing. You couldn't venture it. Your professional career would be destroyed by saying that. It would be like saying destroyed by saying that.
在其他地方，他称之为“反垄断的伤寒玛丽”。罗伯特·博克不仅不喜欢《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》，他厌恶它。因此，在他的写作中，他将其描述为这种疯狂、愚蠢的法律。他创造了这样一种环境，几十年来，任何有价值的经济学家、任何有价值的法律学者，都不会说《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》是一件好事。你不敢冒险。你的职业生涯会因为说出这一点而被毁掉。这就像说
It would be sort of like saying the earth is flat. In the 80s, Bork's ideas made the leap from the page into the halls of power. All throughout government, antitrust positions were filled with appointees who agreed with Bork's philosophy. Laws were reinterpreted and new policy guidelines were issued. The Bork era of antitrust was underway and it was built on the consumer welfare standard. And in this new era, the Robinson-Patman Act wasn't so much killed by authorities as it was disappeared. They just kind of decided, well, we're just going to put that law up on a shelf and we're
这就像说地球是平的一样。在80年代，博克的思想从书页跃入了权力殿堂。在整个政府中，反垄断职位都由认同博克哲学的人担任。法律被重新解释，新的政策指南被发布。博克的反垄断时代开始了，它建立在消费者福利标准之上。在这个新时代，《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》与其说是被当局杀死的，不如说是被消失了。他们只是决定，好吧，我们要把那部法律束之高阁，我们
not going to enforce it. For decades, the Robinson-Patman Act remained up on that shelf, gathering dust. Still technically a law, but ignored. The occasional person might come by and flip through it like an old photo album. But it was understood through different administrations, Republican and Democrat, that this was a thing of the past, a relic of a bygone era of antitrust. That is until the 2010s, when some prominent researchers and legal scholars started to really assess the impacts of its retirement.
不打算执行它。几十年来，《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》一直留在架子上，积满灰尘。虽然在技术上仍然是一部法律，但被忽视了。偶尔有人可能会走过来像翻看旧相册一样翻看它。但在不同的政府（共和党和民主党）中，人们都认为这是过去的事情，是反垄断过去时代的遗物。直到2010年代，一些著名的研究人员和法律学者开始真正评估其退休的影响。
Is it almost like literally the case that businesses are checking the antitrust landscape and are just like, nobody's looking at Robinson-Patman anymore. So like, do whatever you want. Absolutely. I mean, I had, you know, lawyers and even a general counsel at a company tell me that they don't even advise their companies to follow the Robinson-Patman Act because it's not enforced.
企业是否几乎在字面上检查反垄断环境，然后觉得，没人再看《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》了。所以，想做什么就做什么。绝对是。我的意思是，我有律师，甚至是一家公司的总法律顾问告诉我，他们甚至不建议他们的公司遵守《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》，因为它不被执行。
This is Lena Kahn. She was appointed chair of the FTC under President Biden. Kahn is often talked about as the antidote to Robert Bork, which is kind of funny because they're both Yale Law School alums. Yeah, the class where I learned antitrust law in law school had a big portrait of Bork in the back. Did having that portrait like behind you make you feel any kind of way? It felt very apt.
这是莉娜·汗（Lena Kahn）。她在拜登总统任期内被任命为联邦贸易委员会主席。汗经常被谈论为罗伯特·博克的解毒剂，这很有趣，因为他们都是耶鲁法学院的校友。是的，我在法学院学习反垄断法的课堂后面挂着博克的大肖像。那幅肖像挂在你身后让你有什么感觉吗？感觉非常贴切。
I mean, Robert Bork's taught at Yale Law School, the professor who was still teaching anti-trust had been close with Bork, a colleague of his, and so it felt very fitting in that way. Khan is one of the leaders of what's known today as the anti-monopoly movement. And she first rose to prominence after writing a paper that really stuck it to Bork. It's titled Amazon's Antitrust Paradox. And as far as academic papers go, it was a real bombshell, setting off big debates in antitrust circles.
我的意思是，罗伯特·博克在耶鲁法学院任教，当时还在教反垄断法的教授曾与博克关系密切，是他的同事，所以这感觉非常合适。汗是当今所谓的“反垄断运动”的领导者之一。她在写了一篇真正抨击博克的论文后首次声名鹊起。论文标题是《亚马逊的反垄断悖论》。就学术论文而言，这是一枚真正的重磅炸弹，在反垄断圈子里引发了激烈的辩论。
In her research, Lena Khan says that understanding antitrust through Bork's framework is entirely too narrow. It allowed companies like Amazon to amass power with very little scrutiny. And she thought this level of consolidated power has actually resulted in bad outcomes, not just for consumers, but for society. And one way to plainly show these bad outcomes is by looking at what happened to the grocery business. When the government deep-sixed Robinson-Patman, it was too late for the grocery giant AMP.
在她的研究中，莉娜·汗说，通过博克的框架来理解反垄断太狭隘了。它允许像亚马逊这样的公司在几乎没有审查的情况下积累权力。她认为这种集中的权力水平实际上导致了糟糕的结果，不仅对消费者，而且对社会。展示这些糟糕结果的一种简单方法是看看杂货业发生了什么。当政府废除《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》时，对于杂货巨头A&P来说已经太晚了。
The company eventually went out of business. But in its place, another Goliath had emerged. Walmart. In the late 1980s, Walmart entered the grocery business and quickly took a page out of A&P's playbook from back in the day. Well, once the Robinson-Patman Act is shelved, you see big retailers like Walmart start demanding discounts from their suppliers
该公司最终倒闭了。但在它的位置上，另一个巨人出现了。沃尔玛。在20世纪80年代末，沃尔玛进入了杂货业务，并迅速从A&P当年的剧本中借鉴了一页。嗯，一旦《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》被搁置，你就会看到像沃尔玛这样的大型零售商开始要求供应商提供折扣，
and not just demanding discounts, but demanding that they get systematically lower prices than what their rivals are getting. The suspension of Robbins and Patman created a new incentive in the industry. Who could get bigger faster? Because the faster you grew, the quicker you could leverage your size over suppliers.
而且不仅仅是要求折扣，而是要求他们系统性地获得比竞争对手更低的价格。暂停《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》在行业内创造了一种新的激励机制。谁能更快地做大？因为你增长得越快，你就能越快地利用你的规模来压制供应商。
The incentive to get bigger faster resulted in a massive merger spree in the 1990s. Independent and even regional grocers were swallowed up by the big national chains, like Kroger and Albertsons and Safeway, all of which are huge companies in their own right. But even they were looking to bulk up. Certainly when the big grocers have been consolidating, one of the arguments that they make is that we need to get bigger so that we can actually get the same discriminatory discounts that the big guys are.
更快做大的激励导致了90年代的大规模并购狂潮。独立甚至区域性的杂货商被大型全国连锁店吞并，如克罗格、艾伯森（Albertsons）和西夫韦，它们本身都是大公司。但即使是它们也在寻求壮大。当然，当大型杂货商进行整合时，他们提出的论点之一是我们需要做大，这样我们才能真正获得大公司所拥有的那种歧视性折扣。
This new dynamic in the grocery business, rampant consolidation in search of the lowest prices, absolutely decimated small neighborhood grocers. The waterbed effect was in full effect. Big chains like Walmart could extract discounts from suppliers, and in turn, suppliers would make up for any shortfalls by charging smaller stores more. In effect, what you have then is the smaller retailers subsidizing the discounts that Walmart is getting.
杂货业的这种新动态，即为了追求最低价格而进行的猖獗整合，彻底摧毁了小型社区杂货商。水床效应全面生效。像沃尔玛这样的大型连锁店可以从供应商那里榨取折扣，反过来，供应商会通过向小型商店收取更多费用来弥补任何缺口。实际上，你所拥有的是小型零售商在补贴沃尔玛获得的折扣。
And what's going to happen over the long run is those independent grocers are going to get squeezed and are going to get pushed out of the market. For people in places like Woonsocket, Rhode Island, all this consolidation meant more residents had to rely on big chains for groceries. Walmart opened a store in Woonsocket back in 1994, and as the company captured a bigger slice of the market, locally owned grocers felt the pressure. Many of them closed.
从长远来看，会发生什么呢？那些独立杂货商会被挤压，并被挤出市场。对于罗德岛州文索基特这样地方的人来说，所有这些整合意味着更多的居民不得不依赖大型连锁店购买杂货。沃尔玛于1994年在文索基特开了一家店，随着该公司占据了更大的市场份额，本地拥有的杂货商感受到了压力。他们中的许多人关门了。
But in a pattern that has played out in lots of communities, after Walmart helped drive a bunch of grocers out of business. Walmart closed too, only to open a new store in a more central location a few miles down the road in another town. Here's Stacey Mitchell again. You know, kind of looking back at this history, the sort of question becomes, well, you can understand how the suspension of Robinson-Patman led to the demise of independent grocers. But the question becomes like, well, why didn't chains fill those gaps? And the answer is that they didn't have to because we know people have to eat, so they're going to come out to our other stores and we don't have to actually spend
但在许多社区上演的一种模式是，在沃尔玛帮助挤垮了一堆杂货商之后，沃尔玛也关门了，只是为了在几英里外另一个城镇更中心的位置开一家新店。这是斯泰西·米切尔。你知道，回顾这段历史，问题变成了，嗯，你可以理解为什么暂停《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》导致了独立杂货商的消亡。但问题变成了，嗯，为什么连锁店没有填补这些空白？答案是他们不必这样做，因为我们知道人们必须吃饭，所以他们会来到我们的其他商店，我们不必真正花
the money to operate a store in the neighborhood. When Walmart or another big chain leaves town, they don't just abandon the place. Sometimes they make it impossible for other competitors to move in. For example, Walmart owns most of their buildings and when they sell it, they can impose a restriction on the deed, banning, say, another grocer from opening up in the same place. These scorched earth covenants, as they're called, can last decades. So not only are the scales tipped in their favor, but some national grocers are known to salt the earth on their way out.
钱在社区里经营一家商店。当沃尔玛或其他大型连锁店离开城镇时，他们不仅仅是放弃了这个地方。有时他们会使其他竞争对手无法进入。例如，沃尔玛拥有他们的大部分建筑，当他们出售时，他们可以在契约上施加限制，禁止，比如说，另一家杂货商在同一个地方开业。这些所谓的“焦土契约”可以持续几十年。所以不仅天平向他们倾斜，而且一些全国性杂货商在离开时还会“盐渍土地”。
This is the playbook Walmart used to become America's grocer. Today, the company captures one in every four dollars Americans spend on groceries. In some metro areas, Walmart has captured half the grocery market. In others, the number is closer to 70 percent. This is a level of power that is way beyond anything that AMP ever got to. Stacey Mitchell and Lena Kahn both agree that the decline of small local grocers paired with the rise of Walmart and other big national chains has fundamentally altered the food landscape, especially in low income neighborhoods, where these deep concentrations of corporate power have left residents traveling further and further for groceries.
这就是沃尔玛成为美国杂货商所使用的剧本。今天，该公司占据了美国人每花4美元杂货费中的1美元。在一些大都市区，沃尔玛占据了一半的杂货市场。在其他地方，这个数字接近70%。这是一个远远超过A&P曾经达到的权力水平。斯泰西·米切尔和莉娜·汗都同意，小型本地杂货商的衰落加上沃尔玛和其他大型全国连锁店的崛起，从根本上改变了食品格局，特别是在低收入社区，这些深厚的企业权力集中让居民不得不走得越来越远去买杂货。
39 million Americans live in an area that's classified as a food desert. There are food deserts all across the country. There are so many communities that have been hollowed out, where people are struggling on a day-to-day basis. Not having a grocery store nearby is a daily hardship and an indignity. By Robert Bork standards a food desert is actually in its own twisted way an efficient economic outcome. If large companies like Walmart drive out smaller less efficient grocers and nobody chooses to serve that low-income
3900万美国人生活在被归类为“食物沙漠”的地区。全国各地都有食物沙漠。有太多的社区被掏空了，人们在日常生活中挣扎。附近没有杂货店是一种日常的艰辛和屈辱。按照罗伯特·博克的标准，食物沙漠实际上以其扭曲的方式是一种高效的经济结果。如果像沃尔玛这样的大公司挤走了规模较小、效率较低的杂货商，而没有人选择服务那个低收入
community that's not a market failure. It's a market outcome. It's just something that happens. Lena Kahn believes by favoring what Bork would call the most efficient grocers, consumers have been harmed in other ways. The geographic distribution of stores is a problem. The health outcomes of people living in food deserts is a problem. The health outcomes of people living in food deserts is a problem.
社区，那不是市场失灵。这是一个市场结果。这只是发生的事情。莉娜·汗认为，通过偏爱博克所说的最高效的杂货商，消费者在其他方面受到了伤害。商店的地理分布是一个问题。生活在食物沙漠中的人们的健康结果是一个问题。生活在食物沙漠中的人们的健康结果是一个问题。
And in case you haven't paid attention to our politics in the last four years, the price of groceries is still a problem too. The attack line was Robbins and Patman enforcement results in higher prices for people. That was the argument that was offered. But once you try to trace that argument back to actual evidence or support,
如果你过去四年没有关注我们的政治，杂货价格也是一个问题。攻击路线是《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》的执行导致人们的价格更高。这是提出的论点。但一旦你试图将该论点追溯到实际证据或支持，
there's no evidence. It's really arguments that are made on theory, and they're not actually supported by what's happening in the real world. In the real world, national chains have amassed so much power in some places that they're actually able to inflate prices. We saw this play out during the pandemic. At the time, supply chain issues were driving prices up. And big chains used that as an opportunity to turn bigger profits. It was really striking to hear some of the executives from these big grocers talk on their earnings calls, where sometimes there was a recognition that even though the costs were going to go down because those
根本没有证据。这实际上是基于理论的论点，它们并没有被现实世界中发生的事情所支持。在现实世界中，全国性连锁店在某些地方积累了如此多的权力，以至于它们实际上能够抬高价格。我们在疫情期间看到了这一点。当时，供应链问题推高了价格。而大型连锁店利用这个机会赚取了更大的利润。听到这些大型杂货商的一些高管在财报电话会议上谈话真的很令人震惊，有时他们承认，即使成本会因为那些
supply chain issued would resolve themselves, the grocers decided in some cases to keep prices high anyway. And that's something that you can only get away with if you're not being disciplined by competition. The retirement of Robinson Patman was supposed to drive prices down for consumers. But in an industry as consolidated as the grocery business, monopolistic power starts to act in monopolistic ways. And so when Lena Kahn was appointed chair of the FTC, she decided to do
供应链问题自行解决而下降，杂货商在某些情况下还是决定保持高价。而这只有在你没有受到竞争约束的情况下才能做到。退休《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》本应为消费者降低价格。但在像杂货业这样整合的行业中，垄断权力开始以垄断方式行事。所以当莉娜·汗被任命为联邦贸易委员会主席时，她决定做
something bold. So the FTC during my tenure ended up reviving the Robinson-Patman Act. During her time at the FTC, Lena and her team pursued the first Robinson-Patman cases in over 20 years. One of those cases was against Pepsi, which, by the way, doesn't just make soda. They're also one of the biggest suppliers in the grocery sector. Quaker Oats? Pepsi. Ocean Spray? Pepsi. Rolled Gold Pretzels? Pepsi.
一些大胆的事情。所以在我任职期间，联邦贸易委员会最终恢复了《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》。在联邦贸易委员会任职期间，莉娜和她的团队进行了20多年来的首批《罗宾逊-帕特曼法案》案件。其中一个案件是针对百事可乐的，顺便说一句，它不仅仅生产苏打水。他们也是杂货行业最大的供应商之一。桂格燕麦？百事可乐。海洋喷雾？百事可乐。Rolled Gold椒盐卷饼？百事可乐。
It's really just Pepsi all the way down. The FTC's case alleged that Pepsi was giving unfair price advantages to Walmart at the expense of competing retailers. So should I explain waterbeds again? Okay, so if you sit on one side, I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding. You know, I went and visited some of the independent grocers and independent wholesalers that said they were being discriminated against in this way.
真的全是百事可乐。联邦贸易委员会的案件指控百事可乐以牺牲竞争零售商为代价，给予沃尔玛不公平的价格优势。所以我应该再解释一遍水床吗？好吧，如果你坐在这一边，我开玩笑的。我开玩笑的。你知道，我去拜访了一些独立杂货商和独立批发商，他们说他们正以这种方式受到歧视。
And what they would tell me is that if they went to a Costco or Walmart or Target, the prices on the shelves would be lower than what was being made available to them at a wholesale level, which is pretty staggering in terms of just the types of huge price differences that may be happening. For too long, the FTC hasn't been skeptical enough towards monopoly power. Bringing this case was just one way Lena Khan hoped to change that and at the same time show the public that the government can truly take on big problems. I think people had in some ways lost hope that the government would really go back to doing its job in this way. And so I heard a lot from people that, especially for grocers and other independent stores that
他们告诉我，如果他们去Costco、沃尔玛或塔吉特超市，货架上的价格反而比他们从批发渠道拿到的价格还要低，这在价格差异之大方面确实令人震惊。长期以来，联邦贸易委员会（FTC）对垄断力量不够怀疑。提起这起诉讼只是莉娜·汗（Lina Khan）希望改变现状的一种方式，同时也向公众展示政府确实可以解决重大问题。我认为人们在某种程度上已经失去了对政府以这种方式履行职责的希望。所以我从人们那里听到很多声音，特别是对于杂货店和其他独立商店来说，
had been feeling squeezed for a very long time, this was a sign of hope for them. In recent weeks, Trump's FTC voted to drop the Pepsi case, calling it a legally dubious partisan stunt. Lena Kahn says that lawsuit would have helped stop conduct that squeezes small businesses. And dismissing it was a gift to giant retailers. The FTC is still technically pursuing one more Robinson-Patman case, but it's hard to say what the future of that case looks like. Regardless, Kahn's criticisms of Bork's antitrust ideas have already started to make
他们长期以来一直感到被挤压，这对他们来说是一个希望的信号。最近几周，特朗普政府的联邦贸易委员会投票决定放弃百事可乐案，称其为法律上站不住脚的党派噱头。莉娜·汗表示，那场诉讼本有助于制止挤压小企业的行为。而驳回诉讼则是送给大型零售商的一份大礼。联邦贸易委员会在技术上仍在推进另一项《罗宾逊-帕特曼法》案件，但很难说该案的未来会怎样。无论如何，汗对博克（Bork）反垄断理念的批评已经开始产生
an impact. Last year, when the Kroger-Albertson merger was blocked, courts cited evidence that this amount of consolidation would lead to more food deserts and higher prices. Kahn also helped implement new federal merger guidelines, which the Trump administration kept. And that means any merger that crosses the government's desk will have a much higher standard to meet. Not just Robert Bork's consumer welfare standard. Sounds like you're wrapping up.
影响。去年，当克罗格（Kroger）与艾伯森（Albertson）的合并被阻止时，法院援引证据称，这种程度的整合将导致更多的食物沙漠和更高的价格。汗还帮助实施了新的联邦合并指南，特朗普政府保留了这些指南。这意味着任何经过政府审批的合并都必须达到更高的标准，而不仅仅是罗伯特·博克的消费者福利标准。听起来你要结束了。
Yeah, they're wrapping up. You're hanging it up. And you just fill the water up. Hang me out. How old are you? 84? 84. Back in Woonsocket, when me out. How old are you, 84? 84.
是的，他们要结束了。你要收工了。你把水加满。让我挂起来。你多大了？84岁？84岁。回到文索基特（Woonsocket），当我……让我挂起来。你多大了，84岁？84岁。
Back in Woonsocket, when I met up with Jean Michon, she was in her element, inside a kitchen. Jean actually runs an organization named New Beginnings. It's a community kitchen that helps feed some of the city's most food insecure. On a warm, sunny April day, the first of the year, she had 40 paper boxes laid out in a neat square to pack leftovers. That's like none of this goes to waste. No, absolutely not. Absolutely not. I've been doing this 39 years. I don't waste anything.
回到文索基特，当我见到琼·米雄（Jean Michon）时，她正在厨房里忙碌，那是她的主场。琼实际上经营着一个名为“新起点”（New Beginnings）的组织。这是一个社区厨房，旨在帮助喂养城市中一些最缺乏食物保障的人。在一个温暖晴朗的四月天，也就是今年的第一天，她摆放了40个纸盒，整齐地排成一个正方形，用来打包剩菜。这就像是绝不浪费任何东西。不，绝对不会。绝对不会。我做这个已经39年了。我什么都不浪费。
Jean has been around one socket long enough to see a food desert emerge, and she decided to do something about it. The whole organization at New Beginnings has created a vital piece of infrastructure in the city. For a long time, kitchens like hers have helped feed people who don't have the means. But over the years, she's noticed more people drop in who simply can't make it to a grocery store. And to help serve these families, she's planning to work even longer hours. Right now we just do lunch. So if there's working families who can't get to food, they can't get to lunch with us,
琼在文索基特待的时间足够长，亲眼目睹了食物沙漠的出现，她决定为此做点什么。“新起点”整个组织已经在城市中建立了一项至关重要的基础设施。长期以来，像她这样的厨房一直在帮助喂养那些没有经济能力的人。但多年来，她注意到越来越多的人来访，他们只是无法去杂货店。为了帮助服务这些家庭，她计划工作更长的时间。目前我们只提供午餐。所以，如果有上班族家庭无法获得食物，他们就无法和我们一起吃午餐，
we want to expand to do meals at night as well. So we'll reach one population during the day and one population at night. Decades of neglect created One Socket's food desert. Laws went unenforced and corporate power ran amok. Recently, lawmakers in Rhode Island proposed a package of antitrust laws aimed directly at the grocery business, including a local version of a Robinson-Patman Act. But until something really changes, Jean is just gonna be here, in her kitchen,
我们希望扩展到晚上也提供餐食。这样我们白天可以覆盖一部分人群，晚上覆盖另一部分。几十年的忽视造成了文索基特的食物沙漠。法律未得到执行，企业权力横行霸道。最近，罗德岛州的立法者提出了一揽子直接针对杂货业务的反垄断法，包括当地版本的《罗宾逊-帕特曼法》。但在真正发生改变之前，琼只会待在这里，在她的厨房里，
doing her best to serve the people this whole system left behind. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Jason DeLeon and edited by me, Chris Borube, and the team at 99% Invisible. Mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Royale, fact checking by Graham Hayesha. Special thanks this week to Stacey Mitchell over at the Institute for Local Self-Reliance. She's been writing about food deserts in the Atlantic and other publications for years now. You can find links to some of her articles on our website. Also, a special thanks this week to Ethan Shorry over at the Valley Breeze. There are not a lot of local publications covering places like Woonsocket
尽她所能去服务那些被整个系统遗忘的人们。《99% Invisible》本周由杰森·德里昂（Jason DeLeon）制作，由我克里斯·博鲁贝（Chris Borube）和《99% Invisible》团队编辑。马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）混音，斯旺·罗亚尔（Swan Royale）配乐，格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Hayesha）事实核查。本周特别感谢地方自治研究所（Institute for Local Self-Reliance）的斯泰西·米切尔（Stacey Mitchell）。多年来，她一直在《大西洋月刊》和其他出版物上撰写关于食物沙漠的文章。你可以在我们的网站上找到她的一些文章链接。此外，本周还要特别感谢《Valley Breeze》的伊森·肖里（Ethan Shorry）。目前并没有多少地方性出版物在报道像文索基特这样的地方，
at this point, and the archives of the Valley Breeze were tremendously helpful in the research for this story. So thank you. An extra special thank you to Jean Michon and the whole New Beginnings organization. Their work out in Rhode Island is truly heroic. Cathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is our digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor.
而《Valley Breeze》的档案对这个故事的研究非常有帮助。所以谢谢你们。还要特别感谢琼·米雄和整个“新起点”组织。他们在罗德岛所做的工作确实是英雄般的。凯西·图（Cathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Kolstad）是我们的数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。
And the rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lasha Madan, Jacob Medina Gleason, Kelly Prime, and Joe Rosenberg. And of course, Roman Mars is our fearless leader. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stephen Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, temporarily headquartered this week between Providence, Rhode Island and beautiful downtown Toronto, Ontario, Canada. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our Discord server.
团队的其他成员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、拉莎·马丹（Lasha Madan）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森（Jacob Medina Gleason）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）和乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）。当然，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）是我们无畏的领导者。《99% Invisible》的标志是由斯蒂芬·劳伦斯（Stephen Lawrence）创作的。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一员，本周暂时总部设在罗德岛州普罗维登斯和美丽的加拿大安大略省多伦多市中心之间。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们的Discord服务器上找到我们。
There's a lot going on there. You can find a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI, at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那里有很多内容。你可以在99PI.org找到相关链接以及《99PI》过去的所有剧集。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。